very busy Jenna a lot of you guys have
insane jesting what's up with those
circular videos and your blogs
that's from these these are the snapchat
spectacles basically you push this
button you take a video it syncs to your
snapchat and then you can post it so
that's basically what's happening the
little glasses cleaner is in the shape
of the snapchat logo like just freakin
brilliant I love it we're going to need
no I promise let's go so what's with
this terrible upward angle you might be
asking me well my GoPro it's been
destroyed
thanks Matt not the human not not the
dog treats or the dog wash and they've
always got these really good treats in
here I'm gonna take some formatting so
we made it to our food destination we're
gonna go to the doc bars later we're not
sure our friends are gonna join us and
if they don't it's basically just going
to be me and Jenna sitting next to each
other I'm not moving
no go over there it's too bright way to
break god I want the black specks so the
hot cuz these are just so right and they
don't match my everyday outfit no be
good what do you say now then just
normally your sunglasses are okay oh
yeah whatever
hey we've got a friend update one friend
I'm friending it's real bright over yes
real bright yeah you know Sunday
gamer's all right yep and number four is
here hello Jiki come back you're
breaking my arm
a great fun
mady's like what's up did you find any
mom oh yeah oh my god 8000 sad look over
here you can think of yourself so
naughty Haram welcome I just ran into
TJ hello introduce us to your pot this
is Ricky he's my baby boy and Lucy's
over there
so this is so great why'd you finally
get to meet Maddie he's just running
around you like part of the Welcome
committee he goes up and welcomes along
and chases them that's great
welcome I'm pretty good I'm learning
about the new traffic lights cool nice
word that's new traffic Burbank daddy
daddy daddy what you eating what have
you got are you eating someone's fur
what am i doing well somebody broke my
GoPro so this is all you have to use in
the car instead oh god no I can't
dumb stupid thanks for breaking my GoPro
Matt Wow look I guess I'm stuck look at
this great well shot because we have the
camera no okay yeah what does this put
it over there in the corner I think we
should just leave it here it's already
stationed this woman just pulled out of
the gas station and tried to cut in
front of me she goes just point your
finger at me and then she pulling in her
finger at some other woman and pulled
out in front of her
it was the most wild thing I've ever
seen it was pretty great okay so cool
nothing but we get a shot of this huh
what's that cut a big ladder no the
outside that's a red light green light
race then you might want to race so
we've got a lot of things that we're
shopping for today sure on backwards
no Phyllis the game Awards is coming up
so I need to find something to wear I've
got an outfit in mind but I think it's
gonna look dumb so I'm probably not
going to wear it we also have a few
families that were shopping for for the
holidays getting some family gifts yes
I've got it I've got some on Amazon but
the guy did some other ones in store I
picked a family that was asking for Lego
and also there was two little girls that
asked for specific things but I also got
them an extra little Lego set LEGO
Friends I think they're gonna like it
we need to find somewhere we can just
buy a bunch of toys and then like donate
them there's all kinds of like toy
drives and stuff stuff a bus of
Pittsburgh that they allow online
donations really we should do that you
guys have any suggestions let us know
because I feel like Toys for Tots is
always the go-to
yeah yeah we parked around he parked
really loose
Matt's meeting us maybe he'll buy me
something at the mall with all the money
he owes me this list is getting
expensive hey where you going
this sex off looks real festive this is
a glob or what I'm obsessed with this
jacket
it's so cool shirt that's all life this
my stomach huh probably right now
actually so since Matt is coming to meet
us there's something that I do actually
a lot of things that I do that I
publicly embarrass him and he hates to
be publicly embarrassed so you guys know
what I'm doing Matt's not going to what
we doing I'm going to try to embarrass
him too many times like yeah that's true
this is cute that is key oh it's couples
and love couples what the heck is this
expensive ugly shoe send a shot here he
said I got it
Matt look he's running away from me
did you really yell in it yeah heard
yelling we need yours you see how that
works right yeah we get my shoes yeah
seeing something see you something I
don't know how these fit nice no peeking
in the presence ever get press I think I
found an outfit I'm super excited it's
it's uh it ended up not being addressed
which is good so now I gotta find Jenna
and Matt cuz we're gonna go get food
there you are Oh eat one you got it
it's freezing Los Angeles is quite
chilled this explosive winter is coming
it's here it's here you so speedy and
those ghosts come on mac and cheese
steak house Matt's been over there
sneaking pretzels under the table okay
then rise East and a hot oh this is hit
Castro
what's this hey what are you doing is
trying to hack ready ah what's this
so he's sick this is some crostini
this is cool I'm actually excited about
the driving okay cool well thank you
guys for watching I'm gonna end this
video because oh wait I can't end this
video game do you know what else I have
Jen this is something that you go I
dunno so you guys are from like
Pittsburgh East Coast dish there's a
restaurant called eaten Park and at
Eaton Park
they have smiley cookies and in
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania specifically
there are two radio DJs who are my
antennas and pretty much all the city of
Pittsburgh's absolute favorite Mikey and
Big Bob and I know what's in here is
Jenna order showed me hers they are
Mikey and Big Bob smiley cookies frog
eating Park Big Bob Mikey ah oh my god
boy I'll put a link the description
where you guys can actually order these
and 100% of the proceeds goes to
Children's Hospital so that's pretty
awesome and you get delicious cookies
clearly their ship anywhere Sam
California and they're in Pittsburgh
okay I'm gonna go I've got a lot of
cleaning to do can you bite Oh God haha
one camera a few lenses and all of the
cords and cables that I'm going to need
to get the job done so let's open this
up and go through and I'll show you guys
what I have web so inside this pocket
this is a nice secret little compartment
that I like to hide some USB C cables
and the USB C power brick I do have two